touchdown in poland for five u.s
military planes monday carrying some of
the 3 000 extra american troops being
deployed to nato's eastern edges in
response to russia's military buildup
along ukraine's borders
russia could be able
to actually have sufficient forces for a
serious invasion by the end of this
month moscow denies it will invade
ukraine yet a flurry of diplomacy is
aiming to prevent it world leaders and
key players meeting in washington keefe
and moscow
in the russian capital french president
emmanuel macron meeting with vladimir
putin
no breakthrough after talks but the
russian president described their
meeting as useful he wants nato to stop
its expansion east and to prevent
ukraine from joining nato something
experts say is not imminent anyway
macron repeated nato's red lines on
ukraine being allowed to determine its
own future the bloc is proposing
measures on arms control in the region
instead
putin is likely more trusting of macron
their two countries along with germany
and ukraine have been speaking on and
off for eight years to try and resolve
the fighting in eastern ukraine it's the
only format where russians talk to
ukrainians
and so that's the way to bring the
ukrainians at the table good afternoon
german chancellor olaf schultz in
washington where u.s president joe biden
repeated his threat of heavy sanctions
if russia invades there will be no
longer a north stream too
we will bring an end to it but olaf
schultz stopped just short of naming
germany and russia's nordstrom 2 gas
pipeline as a sanction on the table
and we were not taking different steps
we will do the same steps emanuel macron
heads to keeve where he meets with his
ukrainian counterpart vladimir zielinski
tuesday germany's foreign minister is
also heading to the front lines of the
ongoing conflict in eastern ukraine
donna
all right redmond shannon in london
tonight thanks